42 into tuesday morning and it's also i
know you've been waiting for it
national meatball day our own spicy meet
the ball of bianca holmen live this
morning to tell us how to make the
perfect
meatball bianca good morning to you
showing us some amazing food all morning
hey good morning john good morning
everybody at home yeah it is a national
meatball day we're here at di augustino
stratega
where they've been telling us about the
history of meatballs you know they're in
all cultures we've got
you know swedish meatballs we've got you
know fish falls and chinese culture it's
it's
all over but here we're talking about
the italian meatballs
and to tell us more about the history
we're joined by chef dan so tell a chef
about
everyone you know the the from the small
meatballs and italian culture until
serving
spaghetti with meatballs that's not
really kind of traditionally how it's
usually served right no
you will not find in a traditional
italian household you will not
find spaghetti and meatballs on the
table
what you will find is more called a
polpate
which is a smaller version of the
american italian version
um which is typically actually just
served as a main course
you may find pasta on the table in
addition to other
you know salads and bread and things
like that but this is simply a
strictly italian american when the
italians migrated over
they had a little bit more money to
spend on food they got a little bit
indulgent
and they wanted to
entice the americans to uh try their
food so yeah
they knew that americans like to have
starch with their protein
and so it all together they put it all
together what's in your special
meatballs is this so
nate was saying this is a mom's special
or did you put your own twist on it
i just i initially yes i learned how to
make meatballs for my mom
um over the years i have improved on the
recipe
quite a bit with made in jerome
imported ingredients and things but yeah
it's
essentially it's my mom's my mom's
recipe just kicked up about 10 knots
all right perfect and also again you got
something special for folks that they
mention what
here they can get a free meatball right
so mention channel 8 tonight
our hours tuesday through sunday 4 30 to
9 30.
mention channel 8 tonight tomorrow and
thursday and you'll receive a
complimentary uh meatball appetizer for
you look at that looks good
you got to try it and also hey remember
come back here for national uh
ravioli day that's on march 20th and
then over here
next tuesday we got the artichokes is
national artichoke day so you can come
here all month long
and celebrate and eat the amazing food
that they have prepared here
chef and owner dan thanks for hosting us
this morning gonna send it back to you
guys there in the studio
thank you very much if i if i told my
mother that i had tried to improve on a
recipe i'd probably be
disowned but clearly dan knows what he's
doing because that looks amazing so
bianca thank you very much
some tasty stuff appreciate that